Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonjour.
Oscar Wilde a dit :
« La beauté est dans les yeux
de celui qui regarde »,
car tout ce qui entoure la nature
est composé de manière
harmonieuse et équilibrée.
François Cheng énonce :
« L’Univers n’est pas obligé d’être beau,
mais pourtant, il est beau,
et cela nous mène au sens. »
Il est nécessaire de servir
cette harmonie.
Cela peut donner du sens au fait
d'exister et d'être au monde.
Bonjour, je m’appelle Benjamin Fleury,
je vais vous parler du regard
à travers ma pratique architecturale.
L'architecture est l'art de concevoir
et de bâtir des édifices.
Elle se situe à la frontière
entre science et art,
deux manières distinctes de voir.
La science fait appel à l'observation.
Elle est factuelle et sans affect.
Le regard, lui,
est directement lié à l’art.
C’est une manière de voir
beaucoup plus sensitive, personnelle.
Lorsqu’on travaille
sur un projet d’architecture,
au démarrage, on commence
par deux éléments.
Le premier, le lieu.
Le lieu, composé de son histoire,
de sa géographie,
de sa géologie, de son climat.
Et le programme, organisé autour
de ses fonctions, de ses usages,
de ses surfaces et de son coût.
Le travail de l’architecte
est de synthétiser
et de cristalliser ces deux éléments
à travers son regard.
Et c’est à travers ce regard que
le projet acquiert une singularité
et acquiert une âme.
Parce qu'au final, l'architecte ne fait
que construire sa propre vision du monde.
On construit ce que l'on est
et on est ce que l'on voit.
Pour ma part, mon histoire personnelle
a largement contribué
aux choix professionnels que j’ai établis.
Je suis né dans un grand ensemble
à Draveil, aux Mazières,
dans une barre, hors d’échelle,
fonctionnelle et sans âme.
Aujourd’hui, j’ai choisi de rester
en banlieue, à Montreuil,
là où j'habite et là où je travaille.
Naturellement, les projets de l’agence se
sont dirigés vers les logements sociaux,
dans des lieux insalubres
ou dans des grands ensembles,
mon travail étant au final
de revaloriser ces lieux
afin que chacun puisse
y vivre avec fierté,
et ce, à partir du « déjà là »,
soit en réparant les erreurs du passé,
soit en révélant les harmonies oubliées.
À travers quelques projets,
je vais vous montrer comment
mon regard peut cristalliser un projet
entre un programme et un site.
Le premier projet se situe à Pantin,
dans une zone faubourienne,
avec beaucoup de logements insalubres.
Le projet prend place à la place
d’un bâtiment fortement dégradé
qu'on n'a pas pu conserver.
Une des données du projet
est d’accueillir des gens un peu plus
aisés que la moyenne du quartier
dans le but de fabriquer
de la mixité sociale.
Pour cela, la façade sur rue
se veut entièrement effacée.
On a repris le gabarit
des bâtiments voisins, la teinte,
le respect des trois strates historiques
que sont le socle, le corps et la toiture,
et les ornementations
et les proportions de fenêtres
sont à l’identique
de celle des bâtiments voisins.
Côté jardin, le projet est plus théâtral.
Il se plisse afin de se connecter
aux bâtiments voisins
et la façade est revêtue
d’un bardage en mélèze
afin de s’accorder avec le futur jardin.
Lorsque les volets sont fermés,
le projet devient comme une boîte,
un peu étrange, un peu poétique,
et acquiert une forte personnalité.
Maintenant que la végétation a poussé,
on peut voir que la façade
fait corps avec le jardin
et ensemble, ils créent
un îlot protecteur et poétique.
Le second projet se situe à Saint-Denis,
dans une rue avec de beaux bâtiments,
avec de très belles ornementations
en terre cuite.
Nous avons repris le gabarit
des bâtiments existants.
Nous avons repris la matière et nous avons
cherché une ornementation contemporaine
en utilisant deux teintes de brique.
Et le socle, qui était marqué normalement,
simplement sur un niveau,
se trouve en dégradé
avec ces deux couleurs
et propose donc cette ornementation.
Vis-à-vis du projet précédent -
Là, c’est la façade sur rue
qui est plus théâtrale et ostentatoire.
Côté jardin, le projet est plus rationnel.
Il est là pour accueillir
le maximum d’espace extérieur
et le maximum d’ensoleillement
pour les logements.
Et au dernier niveau a été installé
un jardin partagé
pour que les gens puissent communiquer et
déjeuner ensemble sur une table commune.
Le projet suivant se situe à Ecquevilly.
Ecquevilly est un petit bourg qui s’est
développé autour d’un château domanial
avec un centre, une zone pavillonnaire
et un grand ensemble, sans échelle, sans
transition avec l’histoire de cette ville.
C’est un grand ensemble
qui a été imposé par l’État.
Heureusement, il a fait l’objet
d’un renouvellement urbain.
La longue barre que vous pouvez voir
a été déconstruite
et le projet s’installe à la place
de cette grande barre.
Nous avons donc installé
deux îlots avec des logements.
Les logements s’organisent
en périphérie de l’îlot.
Nous avons pris comme objet transitionnel
une des maisons situées en face.
L’objet du projet, c’est de faire en sorte
d’installer une transition apaisée,
historiquement et morphologiquement,
entre la zone pavillonnaire
et le grand ensemble.
Ainsi, vous pouvez voir
des petits bâtiments
qui sont organisés
autour d’un jardin central.
Nous avons pris des toitures
contemporaines,
mais rappelant
les toitures du centre-ville,
Même chose pour les ornementations
de fenêtres :
nous avons pris des ornementations
reprenant celles du village.
Ce bâtiment permet, entre passé et futur,
de retrouver un lien apaisé
entre les [trois] morphologies urbaines
que sont la zone pavillonnaire,
le centre bourg et le grand ensemble.
Le projet suivant se situe aussi
à Saint-Denis,
mais cette fois-ci dans une artère
commerçante et piétonne
située entre une église et la cathédrale.
Le projet prend la place
d’un autre bâtiment insalubre
que les Bâtiments de France et la
mairie voulaient absolument conserver.
Mais le bâtiment était tellement dégradé
qu’il était impossible de le réhabiliter.
Nous l’avons aussi choisi
en tant qu’objet transitionnel,
mais cette fois-ci,
cet objet transitionnel va disparaître.
On voulait faire un hommage à ce bâtiment
et en garder la mémoire.
Pour cela, nous avons créé
un bâtiment contemporain
en reprenant tous les éléments
de l’ancien bâtiment.
On a une série de fenêtres posées
à l’identique de l’ancien bâtiment,
encadrements de fenêtres
et garde-corps aussi à l’identique
afin de rappeler cette mémoire.
Cette fois-ci, entre passé et futur,
on a voulu conserver entièrement
la mémoire du passé
et d’une manière entièrement
contemporaine pour autant.
Voici une photo où on peut voir
les encadrements contemporains
et un garde-corps qui rappelle
le garde-corps passé.
Le dernier projet se situe à Montreuil.
Il s’agit d’un projet passif, donc à très
basse consommation énergétique,
en accession sociale à la propriété.
La difficulté de ce projet était
de proposer des prix réduits
pour des acquéreurs avec peu d’argent,
venant du logement social.
Le fait qu’ils deviennent acquéreurs
libère d’autres places
dans des logements sociaux
pour des gens qui en ont plus besoin.
Donc, il y avait un équilibre économique
très complexe à trouver
pour proposer ce bâtiment passif
et à la fois pas cher à l’achat.
Comme pour le projet d’Ecquevilly,
la morphologie du bâtiment permet
de faire une transition
entre la zone pavillonnaire à gauche
et les plots de la modernité
situés à droite.
Le bâtiment est composé de deux plots,
l’un sur rue et l’autre sur jardin.
Afin de faire des économies d’énergie,
mais aussi des économies de construction,
on a choisi d’utiliser une seule cage
d’escalier et un seul ascenseur,
le second bâtiment étant relié au premier
par des passerelles
que vous pouvez voir ici.
Ces passerelles,
qui, à la base, avaient un but simplement
environnemental et économique,
sont devenues le lien social
de tous les habitants.
C'est là où tout le monde se croise
et où tout le monde discute.
Voici une photo que les habitants
m’ont envoyée pendant le confinement.
On est à 20 heures, ils sont en train
de chanter en l’honneur de nos soignants.
Ils m’ont envoyé ce gentil mot,
en me remerciant
de leur avoir proposé cette architecture
qui leur permettait d’avoir du lien social
et en même temps,
un projet entièrement singulier.
Pour finir, je dirais que
mon travail et mon regard
me permettent de révéler
et d’agir sur les espaces habités
sur lesquels je travaille, de manière
à reconnecter les hommes.
Le Clézio énonce : « Être vivant,
c’est d’abord savoir regarder.
Et savoir regarder, c’est s’ouvrir
au monde, c’est être curieux,
se débarrasser de ses préjugés
afin d’agir sur son environnement
et sur les relations humaines
d’une manière harmonieuse et positive. »
Merci.
(Applaudissements)